diesen schawarm habe ich nicht im
Restaurant gekauft aber er schmeckt
mindestens genauso gut zugegeben wir
brauchen wirklich eine Vielzahl an
Gewürzen die geben wir einfach zu
unserem schicken und marinieren das
ganze die Gewürze stehen hier oben dazu
ein bisschen weißen Essig oben drüber
das Chicken ist schön bedeckt jetzt
wollen wir es noch ein bisschen
flüssiger bekommen dafür gehen wir
Zitronensaft Tomatenmark und ein
bisschen Olivenöl an wenn unser Hähnchen
mariniert ist solange wir Geduld habt
geben wir es auf den Grill so braten wir
das Hähnchen perfekt golden braun durch
und es riecht jetzt schon no joke wie im
Schawarma Shop wenn unser Hähnchen
ordentlich Farbe hat gebe ich dir auch
ein Bett ich mache das einfach hier mit
meinem spachteln ein bisschen klein und
fertig ist das perfekte schon warmer
chicken wir nehmen uns zwei arabische
Fladenbrote und erwärmen die ein
bisschen Brot raus überlappend hinlegen
erstmal ein bisschen Knoblauchsoße
schicken arabische salzige Gurken und
paar Tomaten zum Schluss
Granatapfelsirup rollen wir den Lachs
Seiten rein rüber klappen und zack
bisschen Öl drüber und antosen jetzt nur
noch ein Rollen da da und fertig ist der
selbstgemachte